the Joe Rogan experience way I'm reading
this book about Kit Carson and the Old
West and when the United States
you know conquered parts of California
and and took over parts of California
and in the West from Mexico and it was
crazy back then yeah yeah and they were
talking about the chaos in in the
Mexican government and the Mexican
military back then in the 1800s
yeah yeah I mean so so people kind of
figured realized if you want to be an
officer in the in the Mexican army you
have to go through War College and
there's different ways to go about it
but there's a lot of hereditary stuff
going on errata Terry okay my dad was a
general okay yeah there's a lot of that
going on also the army down there has a
monopoly over selling guns it's only one
gun store in all of Mexico and it's run
by the end of the army what yep one guns
going on and all Mexico is run by the
army and you have to fly to Mexico City
to to get a license and to procure a
firearm so if you live in the Yucatan
you have to fly them and get a fly to
Mexico City to get a gun which makes
which basically makes the only options
buying a gun on the black market or
flying over there and expending all this
money so there's a now it's a class so
only only people that can afford the
plane ticket and to do all this process
are the ones that can have guns so it's
a that's class you know the class is
involved in there as well
what kind of rights do you have with
guns versus the United States Second
Amendment is it so the Constitution the
Mexican Constitution allows for guns for
self-defense but a lot of amendments and
a lot of corrupt governments and they're
said you maybe you're not a good idea to
have this here so progressively
throughout a Mexican region Mexican
history it's become more and more strict
all right certain rounds aren't allowed
certain calibers aren't allowed and this
just plainly the sale of firearms in all
of Mexico is just relegated to a single
gun store in Mexico City so you can't
carry them without a lot without a
permit and to get a permit you have to
know somebody who knows the Presidente
or
or something but what about all those
gentlemen we saw in that video just
walking in front of those government
agents with with guns why didn't they
arrest them they should have they should
have been like there's a long break the
only people that respect those laws are
you know law-abiding citizens there was
a case in Veracruz of an old man a
former army guy old older gentleman his
son tried to get abducted and some
something like that he had this old
Mauser rifle and he shot dead one of the
guys that was chasing him is trying to
abduct him he was arrested for the the
firearm possession and the Hauser's
would leave Harvey Oswald supposedly
used on JFK yeah that's an old ass gun
well there's a lot of weird old ass
stuff down there I mean as far as the
stuff that gets handed over or just the
weird exotic firearms down there a lot
of people called Mexico the u.s. is a
garage and likely like garages you just
find weird stuff down there from over
War two ERA pistols and Explosives to
new stuff like there's a friend of mine
that works for the government down there
told me that they found a bunch of parts
for a mini gun in it you know how
somewhere down there what's a mini gun
it's basically a remember that go ahead
remember that Terminator 2 yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah pretty hard to get you know
one of those apparently there's one out
there somewhere on a vehicle of some
sort well Jesus it's basically a
obliterate everything
[Applause]